Health Secretary Matt Hancock has said
he would not rule out the option of
compulsory vaccinations saying
campaigners against jabs have blood on
their hands last week
UNICEF released figures showing that
more than half a million children in the
UK went unvaccinated against measles
between 2010 and 2017 Matt Hancock has
blamed anti vaccine messages on social
media for encouraging skepticism among
parents this is a problem across Europe
where Italy and France have introduced
compulsory vaccination Matt Hancock is
right to be harsh against the selfish
and unscientific ignorance of
anti-vaxxers they increase the risk for
all children but and this is a capital
but I cannot accept compulsory
vaccination instead Germany's examples
should be pursued fine parents all you
like but granting the states so much
power that it can inject us with
substances against our wishes is taking
public health one Orwellian step too far
history doesn't need to remind us why
the Germans chose not to go down this
route
[Music]
Majid and this is a tough one you know
I'm not a parent but I sympathise with
parents and I understand the ones that
are skeptical of vaccinations but the
problem is there is no proof you know a
lot of people are scared because they
think it causes autism and so on but
there's no proof of that and actually
when you look at what's happening
particularly in America where the sort
of lovey mummies are not vaccinating
their kids it's causing a mini epidemic
in areas like Brooklyn and those you
know found in Heights and so on and I
think that actually I kind of agree with
Matt Hancock I don't think we can allow
this to go unchecked can I just bring in
some stats so if we look at where new
vaccines were introduced in 1963 measles
killed around 2.6 million people a year
and approximately 110,000 people died
for measles in 2017 and they were mostly
children under the age of five and if
you sort of add that figure up over that
period of time
these vaccines have saved approximately
around 20 million people yeah I don't
know how we say we can't do something
I'm not disputing the extent of the
problem and it's why I think the
conspiracy theorist anti-vaxxers are as
I said unscientific selfish and ignorant
but it is important to note that what
you just mentioned there about the
epidemic in America is in Brooklyn in
particular among Orthodox Jewish
communities and that's why it's so
important and also the lovely mummies -
yes but in Brooklyn New York that you
refer to it's Orthodox Jewish
communities for religious reasons aren't
getting vaccinations or whatever their
reasons are so it's important to put
that into the context of compulsory
State vaccinations and the Nuremberg
trials refer to refer to this because of
course Nazis were engaged in this and
not least against Jewish charities and
it's just imagine how scared certain
communities were 60s against Africa - I
totally understand where you're going
can I just read from that from your
cursor from the Nuremberg trials it says
the voluntary consent of a human subject
is absolutely essential this means that
the person involved should have legal
capacity to give consent should be so
situated as to be able to exercise free
power of choice without the intervention
of any element of force fraud deceit
duress overreaching or other ulterior
form of constraint or coercion and
should have sufficient knowledge and
comprehension of the elements of the
subject-matter involved as to enable him
to make an understanding and enlightened
decision others snick what I've got the
solution it doesn't happen often and I'm
terribly sorry matter because when I now
unveil the solution it will be the end
of your conversation and just before I
unveil my solution across purposes
because you don't like the idea of
Germany finding so hang on a second
so it's alright okay so it's alright not
to have your child vaccinated as long as
you pay money either you want herd
immunity or you don't know how campaign
money makes it alright let's stop use
the states of force people to inject
their children but if they don't inject
it should be penalty should be so it
makes it alright to put your kid out and
ruin herd immunity if you paid the state
a few marks no you I'm hoping that it
doesn't I've got the solution anymore
yeah I have been debating this on radio
shows since the largely discredited
research by dr. Antle
Andrew wait Hill came up many many years
ago and what mums and dads phoned up and
told me then is what they tell me now
which is their concern is that the MMR
the three doses in one go is too much
now scientifically it's fine
everybody but there is nothing more
valuable than your child every parent
around here knows you live them separate
them you separate them now there is a
cost to that okay but everybody I've
ever said this to who's saying you will
always get the people who concern so why
don't you do them over a period of a few
months there is a cost to that so they
just bear the cost of conspiracy
theories will still object what you'll
never get to them you'll never get to
them
but I do hear a parent's valid concern
giving my kitty
the sireesha plus a booster if it's so
great white why do we need a booster if
it's so brilliant why would a drug Nick
bring you to that so we do what we will
do mumps one miserably rubella you've
got a pest forty quid a shot every
parent to do it who's up next
who's talking it's because I've solved
this one what do you think specifically
of Jeanne said she endorses it map
Hancock's suggestion which is what has
become confident I'm not gonna have a
cup of tea I want to bring in a parent
who I think I think it's really
important with what you're saying but I
think it's important not to be
dismissive of people's concerns about
vaccinations majid and not to write it
off as ignorance because actually I
found that parents who are concerned
often have done more research than those
of us might i've vaccinated my daughter
with all the standard vaccinations she's
fine knows she's fine but did i feel
that there were health professionals who
were willing to have a take the time to
remove walk me through the wrists no all
parents want to make sure their child is
safe when you have a small child you're
very conscious of you know small
children very robust but they're also
fragile and then i do of injecting your
child with a quite large dose of
vaccinations is quite scary to a lot of
parents and I can understand why parents
are weary I just want to show you this
is a woman called Lottie Daley who's
explaining that anti-vaxxers perspective
the Nuremberg code for example states
that we shouldn't have
medical procedure done to us without our
implicit and consent so therefore for
thing someone to vaccinate is wrong I
also think it's quite a totalitarian
approach and even if you don't believe
in facts nature you do believe in it it
shouldn't matter it's about the freedom
to choose what's right in an informed
capacity I think that there are a lot of
complicated reasons why people do not
trust the state or medical professionals
one is religion and I relate that to
other conversations about sex education
where religious communities do not trust
the state deciding what their children
should have more they should know and
like I think it is important our
children of vaccinated and that they
have sex education but I think you have
to build trust having a concern as a
parent is very different so actively
campaigning against and yes but my
concern is that all this debate is about
just before Michelle comes in is all
about compulsion rather than about
trying to build trust and understand why
people are skeptical and the idea that
you force them to have it all that you
find them which is all that you ban
their children from school I think it's
completely the wrong approach we need to
be looking at the root causes of why
this mistrust exists so I'm a big
believer in prevention rather than cure
particularly in all of these days of
strained NHS I think anything we can do
to prevent people from getting ill in
the first place is good by me so I'm in
favor of vaccination when it comes to
monetary verses almost motivation to do
the choice yourself it's really hard
sometimes to motivate parents to do the
right things then in Australia and I'll
get criticized for saying this but they
have a no job no pay policy which they
expanded then it's been no job no player
which don't even know about but what
they've said there is if you don't
vaccinate your children they will stop
you if you're in receipt of various
family benefits they will stop you
having access to those benefits if you
also don't vaccinate your children and
when you put them into play centres play
areas you have to prove and you have to
give a certificate of vaccination if you
don't you won't be allowed to go into
those those play centres and those those
initiatives have had a remarkable impact
in terms of getting parents to vaccinate
their children because I earned when I
was looking at the religious reasons for
not vaccinating I found
so many places that was dispelling that
myth and actually saying that there's no
religion in the land that truly dictates
that you can vaccinate there might be
arguments that say there's I don't know
whether it's gelatine or whatever it is
in some of these vaccines but there's no
true religious reasons and for me I
believe in head immunity I do believe in
immunization being a group activity and
I think it's quite selfish and wrong for
individual parents to put their desires
over that group mentality and group
wellness